Сергій шкарлут міністр освіти та науки
України далі долучається до нашого ефіру
п міністр вітаємо
дякую вам
Отже війна завдала серйозного удару і по
українській освіті як бачимо тисячі
учнів змушені навчатися дистанційного
ситуацію ускладнюють відключення
електроенергії нині в Україні
завершується зимові канікули чи бачите
ви тенденцію до зростання кількості
школярів та їхніх батьків готових до
очної форми навчання
Дуже дякую вам за запитання і дуже дякую
за постійну увагу до питання освіти адже
це я завжди кажу освіта це про майбутнє
Звісно зараз закінчується зимові
канікули і в нас е-е Причому на сьогодні
працює
26 шкіл з яких 80% Вже вийшло зимових
канікул 2900 шкіл ще перебувають але це
той самий освітній процес який в
будь-якому випадку формується відповідно
до графіку освітнього проце на сьогодні
2-3 шкіл працюють в очному або в
змішаному форматі Це більше ніж 66%.
тобто 3 900 3955 ще працюють у
традиціїному очному форматі
4608 шкіл працюють у змішаному форматі і
4363 школи працюють виключно в
дистанційному в онлайн форматі на
сьогодні в цілому більше ніж 3 мільйони
970 школярів 3 млн 970 тисяч учнів
взагалі задіяний в освітньому процесі з
них понад два мільйони 300 учнів
навчаються змішана або в традиційному
форматі
звісно є області які взагалі В 5
областях у нас немає жодної школи яка
працює в очному або змішаному форматі це
Донецька Запорізька Луганська Харківське
Херсонської області це пов'язано перш за
все з безпекової ситуації і перш за все
з тим що там постійно є арт-обстріли
які які там де ворожий артилерія добиває
до цих територій але але якби навіть по
території где окупованих ми бачимо що
освітній процес відновлюється в нас це
тішить адже жодна дитина не має бути
підлучена відсторонена від освітнім
процесу дуже дякую вам за запитання
давайте ще поговоримо про тих хто
навчається за кордоном понад півмільйона
учнів були змушені покинути Україну
навантаження на більшості з них дуже
високе вони повинні відвідувати місцеві
школи в тих країнах Де знайшли прихисток
водночас продовжують вчитися в
українських школах дистанційно що робить
Міністерство аби з одного боку зменшити
навантаження на таких дітей а з іншого
не втратити їх для нашої Української
освіти
а Дуже дякую за запитання саме в цьому
контексті ми проводили декілька кодів з
моїми колегами міністрами освіти країни
Європейського Союзу на сьогодні ще раз
наголошує лист роз'яснення є методичні
рекомендації Міністерства освіти в яких
чітко зазначає це що діти які
перебувають в інших країнах на сьогодні
під час воєнного стану їх результати
навчання враховуються в успішності і в
атестації в українських закладах після
повернення є певна інформаційна довідка
встановлено зразка який дитина має
привести і докласти
в закладі освіти ми визнаємо повністю
результати навчання в будь-якій країні
чітко Хочу зазначити що не обов'язково
ніяких вимог обов'язковості
паралельного навчання наприклад в
закладі освіти Польщі і одночасно в
закладів освіти в українському немає
сьогодні
визнання
результатів в інших країнах і це показав
і перший семестр зараз показує другий
семестр абсолютно всі діти атестовані та
більовані навіть дисципліни яких не
вивчали дитина в іншій країні і при
поверненні в Україну сьогодні буде
процес атестація лише по цій дисциплінах
якщо
в нас є також інші форми навчання
наприклад сімейна наприклад домашня або
екстернатна дистанційна форма як І
взагалі не потребують результатів визна
зараховується автоматично і
сьогодні освітній процес дитини
визначається саме національним
законодавством України перебування саме
це Ми якраз обговорювали з моїми
колегами Дуже дякую за запитання то
розуміємо пане Сергію Дякуємо вам Сергій
шкарлет міністр освіти та науки України
був разом з нами наживо